hey everyone
welcome to this javascript crash course
video
in this session we bring to you all the
fundamental concepts of javascript
but before we begin make sure to hit the
subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
first let's have a look at the agenda
for the session
first we look at a simple hello world
program using
javascript then we'll understand the
different types of areas deployed in
javascript
we look at the concept of loops objects
this keyword and functions in detail
then we learn about form validation
javascript regular expressions and
javascript email validation
then we'll move on to more advanced
topics like promises
and async await so without further delay
let's begin hey guys welcome to another
video by simply learn
in this video we will learn all about
javascript and write our first program
using this language
so without further ado let's begin
what's in it for you now we'll start by
understanding what javascript actually
is
then we will get to know why it is so
popular these days
and lastly we will write our first
program in javascript
which will print hello world in the
browser window
so what is javascript javascript is a
dynamic
computer programming language which is
lightweight and object oriented
now the best part about javascript is
the fact that it's open source
and is cross-platform compatible meaning
one piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used is a part of
web pages it allows client-side script
to interact with the user
and make dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why javascript
now being the most popular language in
the world javascript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
javascript is now being used in many
industrial fields such as web
development
mobile application development and also
game development
it is very diverse in nature
there are great career opportunities for
javascript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute a simple program
to understand javascript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is a text editor
in this case we've used the vf code
editor
so now let's go to our text editor that
is vs code
and here let's open a file let's say
file and now you can type in your code
here
so we will have to add the javascript to
the html code and then print out the
words hello world
on the browser window right that's our
objective so let's add the html
boilerplate
in this file so let's type in
html is our tag
and then next we have the body type so
within the body tag
we can add the script tag to insert the
javascript into html page
right so we say script
language equals javascript
and type equals
text slash
javascript all right
let's close the tag and then
in the script we call a javascript
function that is document.write which
writes the string to our html page
right so we say document
dot write and within braces we say
hello world
okay and now we close the tags
you also close the body
and finally
all right
now when we save the file we're going to
save it
say on my desktop and i'm going to call
it index
dot html right so make sure the
extension is html
and then save it and then it says
already exists
i say replace it and now once you save
it as an html file you can see that the
colors have appeared
so any errors will be easily indicated
here
so now let me save this and now let's go
ahead and execute
the file data store
so let me go back to my desktop
and here i have index.html
there you go when you click on the file
it opens in your browser
and you can see the words hello world in
this we will be learning
all about javascript arrays and the
popular methods of the array object
so what's in it for you we'll start by
understanding what a javascript array is
then we will get to know about the
operations that we are performing on the
array
after that we'll get familiar with some
of the most used array methods
and lastly we'll go through map reduce
and filter functions
so what exactly is an array now an array
object lets you store multiple values in
a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now an array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative areas can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what array
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in javascript
but let's start by creating an array so
for that
let's go ahead and create a folder first
which will consist of the file that
we're creating right
so for that let me just
go ahead and create a folder
and i'll call it demo underscore adding
so once you're done with that open your
visual studio code editor
and here say open folder
and click on demo array
okay it's creating the workbench all
right and now
here you can see the new file icon so go
ahead
and create demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
html tag
and here i have the head tag
and let me say javascript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag i create a
paragraph tag
and create an id and let me call it
demo and then close the tag
now i'll explain to you why we're doing
this a little later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so say script
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword
let and say we give the name of the
array cars
equals in square base braces we say
bmw and
volvo and then say
honda all right so now
we create an array now one more thing is
that we use the keyword let
so that which indicates that the array
can be changed throughout the program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so
i say document
[Music]
dot get element by id
and here i say now the id
created was demo so i say demo here
and i use the dot inner html property
which is equal to cars okay let me
change this to bmw first
all right so what exactly inor html does
is that it is responsible for what is
being displayed on the web page
okay now since we've taken id as demo
any
changes made is reflected in this id and
then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here i go back to my folder and then
to the file
and go ahead and click on it
so there you go the heading is displayed
and the entire array is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so i hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
so the next operation is to access an
array element
so let's go back to our vs code and here
let's create another variable say let
bmw bmw's
variable don't get confused with the
array element so bmw equals
cars of the index 0.
so basically cars of 0 is nothing but
bmw
all right so that is being saved in the
variable bmw
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so let's just copy this
and place it here and instead of cars
you use the
variable name bmw that is this one
all right so now let's save this
and when we
it you see bmw here
that's how you retrieve an element from
an array
next up we have the addy length property
which displays the length of the array
so again let me show you how to do that
let's go back to our code
and here let's create a variable
and let's call it length variable so i
say let
l e n equals cars
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that
and now after this again let's just
copy the same code here and then
let's pass len okay
now let's save this and when you execute
it again
it says three so we've successfully
retrieved the length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element
right so let's go back to our vs code
and now
let's create another variable and let's
call it
last and we'll just say
last equals cars
and within square braces cars dot length
minus one right
so basically the length of the array is
three and three minus one is two
so it should retrieve cars of 2 which is
honda right so let's just
execute this let me pass last here
save it and see if it displays honda for
us
there you go it's as simple as that
all right so moving on the next array
operation
is loop over an array item
so for that let's go to our code
and here let's use the for loop
so i say cars dot for
each for each
and within this we'll say
item
comma index comma
array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so i say
console console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's save this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your
web page right because whatever is being
printed has to be printed in your
console
so now click on f12 which opens the
developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that and now you can see the name of the
item in the array
along with its index so you see bmw 0
volvo 1
and honda 2. all right
so moving on now that we've learned
about the array operations
let's go ahead and learn about the array
methods
so the first method is tostring now as
the name suggests
it is used to convert an array into a
string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last i just say
cars dot to string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string so
let's save this
and let's execute it all right now here
the same output is shown
which means that the type has only been
changed to string type
all right moving on the next method
is pop now pop basically removes the
last element from the array
so let me show you how that works let's
go back to our vs code and here
we have to save the pop element into a
variable
right so let's create a variable say
last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
[Music]
last one of cars dot pop now you can use
the pop method
to pop the element and now
we can just copy the same code
to display this onto our web page and
here
i just say last one
now since we've popped the last element
the array has only two elements right
that is bmw and volvo
so if you want to display the last
element it should display
volvo right so what we can do is we can
just create another variable say last
two
and just use the same logic here
okay and now let's just
displayed on your console and let's say
last
two all right so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one
which is displayed on the web page and
the last element of the array after the
pop function
has to be displayed on our console so
let's go ahead and
execute the file
all right so honda has been displayed
that is the element that has been
removed from the array
and now once we check our console
here you go here you can see volvo which
means that is the last element in the
array
moving on the next method is the push
method
now as the name suggests it is used to
add a new element to the array
and remember to the end of the array so
let's go back to our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push push is the method that we're
using
inside of which we'll say audi
all right and now let's just display the
same things
so let me copy this
and here let me say cars
okay so let me save it and once
i execute it it says bmw volvo and audi
so we've successfully added another
element to the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array
now this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indexes
of every element by one all right let me
show you how this works so let's go back
to
our vs code and here let me just say
cars dot shift
it's as simple as that and let's just
display this
let me copy the same thing
let's save it and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays volvo
and audi so now cars
has array elements volvo and audi with
at a indices 0 and 1.
all right so moving on the next method
is unshift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method
therefore this method increases the
array index by one
right so let's go back to our vs code
and use the same function unshift
so let's say cars dot unshift
and here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding
right let me say hyundai
okay let's save this
and when we execute it you can see
hyundai volvo and audi
as simple as that all right moving on
the next method is the concat method
now this is basically used to merge two
different areas
right so let's go back to our vs code
ensure let's create another array first
and let's just call the array bikes
okay and let's create say
yamaha
and let's say suzuki
and then we'll say royal enfield okay
and now let's save this
and say let vehicles this is another
array
which is basically the after
concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right
so let's say cars dot concat
or bikes we just concat bikes
and cars together okay and then let's
just
display this over the web page so
let me change this to vehicles
all right let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method
now basically sort is used to sort the
entire array into ascending order
all right so let's go back to our editor
and here let's just use the
sort method on the array vehicles
all right vehicles dot
sort okay
and let's just
display this on our web page so
again let's go back and
execute it and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method is the reverse method
so the reverse method is again used to
reverse the elements in an array
so it's logic right so sort was used to
sort it in ascending order
now when you reverse it it just sorts it
in this ascending order
so let's go back here i'm going to copy
the same thing
all right and here instead of sort let
me just say
reverse so let's save this
and execute it there we go
it has displayed the entire array in the
reverse order
all right with that we finish the area
methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map now the map
method
is used for creating a new array from an
existing one
by applying a function to each and every
one of the elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right
so to make you understand this better
let's go back to our
visual studio code and now here
let's first create another area okay
so let me call this num1
and let's have integers let's say 2
3 4 5.
six and seven okay
and now let's have another array
num2
let's go ahead and say num1
dot map of let me define a function
say multiply okay
so multiply the function that is that
i'm going to define here
so let's say function multiply
of value okay and inside this let me say
return
value into two
okay so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1
by 2 and saves the new elements into the
array num2
okay now after this let's go ahead
and display the contents so let me copy
this
and let's display the content in the
array
num2 right so let me save it
let's go back here execute it
so there we go every element has been
multiplied by 2
and then displayed again i hope this was
clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method
takes each element in an array and
applies a conditional statement against
it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array
but if it returns false the element does
not get pushed
all right so let me show it to you
now let's
go ahead and create another
variable say num3 and here i say
num1 dot filter
of say comp now comp is a function
let me define the function here
let me say function
comp of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which i'm going to check if the
value is greater than 4.
now it only appends the element into the
array num3
if the value is greater than 4 all right
so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3 all
right
let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go now the values so let's go
back here let me check
now num1 had the values two three four
five six and seven right so according to
this
it has to only display 5 6 and 7. do not
get confused with num2 here
we've passed num1 here so it checks put
this array
right so according to the logic it
should display
5 6 and 7 and it has done so here
okay moving on
the next method is the reduce method
now the reduce method reduces an array
of values
down to just one single value now to get
the output value
it runs a reducer function to each
element of that
array okay now this method does not
reduce the original array
again so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create another
variable say num4 and say num1
dot reduce and let me call it sum
so what we're basically doing is that
we're adding all the
digits 2 3 4 5 6 and 7 in num1
to a single value right that is the sum
and then we're going to be displaying
that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here
function sum
basically is total comma value right
and then here let's say return
total plus the value
okay and after this
i'm going to display the content
so let's say num 4
okay let's save it go back
and execute here we go it displaces some
of the entire
values in the array we're learning all
about javascript loops
if you're new to javascript i suggest
you go through our previous videos on
this topic
so without further ado let's begin and
look at what's in store for you
so we're going to be covering topics
like for loop
while loop which also includes the do
while loop and then we're going to learn
about breaking out of a loop
and then we'll see how to skip a loop
cycle
before proceeding make sure you
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update
now before jumping into the for loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is
right so a loop is basically a
programming construct
that executes a piece of code as long as
a certain condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of loops we have
entry control loops and exit control
groups
now what exactly are entry control loops
now these are the loops
where the test condition is checked
before
executing the piece of code for example
you have the for loop and the while loop
so in their case before entering the
loop the condition is checked
and only if the condition is met it
enters the loop and executes the code
all right when it comes to exit control
loops the test condition is checked
after the loop has been executed
all right so in this case the loop at
least gets executed i mean the code in
the loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is the two while
loop
all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead
and learn about the different loops
so the first loop is the for loop all
right
so what exactly is a for loop this is
the basic
logic and the flowchart in front of you
so what exactly happens
is that say for example you want to
print the word looping
say 10 times right so what you can do is
you can start and you can have a for
loop
which goes from 0 to 9 and
then you increase the number by 1 every
time you print the loop
once it's equal to 10 or even greater
than 10
it ends the loop right so let me
help you understand this better with an
example
so let's go to our editor that is vs
code
here i've created a folder called demo
underscore loops
within which i've created a file called
for loops all right
so now let's just write down our initial
code for html that is
html and then i have a head tag
[Music]
within which i say javascript
loops all right
now i have a body tag
[Music]
within which i give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading say
javascript
[Music]
for loops all right
let me just call it for loop
now let's have the script tag
[Music]
within which i'll have
a variable say x
and now we have the for loop so we say
for
x equals 0
x less than 5
x plus plus
within which i say console.log
of x so basically
what happens is now you have the first
variable which is called the counter
variable now this keeps track of how
many times the code is being executed
right and next i less than 5 is the
condition
now the loop keeps executing as long as
the condition is met
and lastly the counter variable is
incremented and usually it's incremented
by one
right so here we've done the same thing
and inside the loop we print the value
of x
all right so let me save the file and
then execute it
all right it's printed javascript loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad i missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag
so let me just
change it here now let's
save this let's go back and just refresh
the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here
all right so now since we're printing
the value of x on our console
we'll have to inspect our element so
let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4.
all right now this is a simple for loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for loop so first the condition is
checked
and if the condition holds true then the
code is
executed and if it is false it
terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to
javascript while loop all right
let's just delete this and here
let's initialize the value of x to 1
and now i say while x
less than or equal to 5
within braces i say console.log
of x and then i increment the value of x
all right so let me save this
and let's execute the file
all right so it says javascript while
loop and let's
inspect and here in our console
it displays the values of x
all right so according to the logic
x is initially initialized to 1
and the value gets executed once it
enters the while loop
all right it's incremented and then
checked every time
until the value reaches 6 right
and then it breaks from the loop since
the value does not hold true
and then it terminates so this is a
logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop now here
as you can see first the code is
executed
and then the condition is checked if the
condition is true
then the code execution continues and if
it falls it's terminated
all right so this is an exit control
loop
also in an exit control loop the code is
executed at least
once so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just delete this now
let's initialize
x to say 15
all right and now i use the do keyword
within which i write the code so first
i'm going to print the value of x
console dot log of x
and then i increase my value
and here i mentioned my test condition
which is while
x less than say 10.
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is x and once it
enters the loop
here it should print the value of x
which is 15
all right and then it increments the
value but once it
comes out of the loop it checks for the
condition here the condition says less
than 10
but since x is not less than 10 it
prints the value x
that is 15 and then terminates all right
so let's
save this and execute it
so let me execute this
and here let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value
15 first and then check the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to say
5 all right so now it enters a loop
and then it prints the value of x and
then increments it
and when it comes out of the loop and
checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10
it prints it okay so let's
save this go back here
and let's refresh the page and here you
can see the values
5 to 9 are printed so this is how the do
while loop works
moving on to the next concept breaking
out of a loop
now as the name suggests break is the
keyword that is used to break out of a
loop
now here is a simple code for you so
according to the logic
it prints the values between 1 to 10.
and say at the value 5 you want to break
out of the loop
you can simply use the keyword break so
let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just make it
simple unsave
for x equals one
x less than or equal to 10.
let's increment it
and within the loop let's
display the value x on the console and
then
we're going to check for the condition
if x equals 5
all right so if x equals 5
we break out of the loop so let's save
the file
and execute it and there you go
it's displayed the values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
loop is executed
and once the value of x reaches 5 it
breaks from the loop
simple right all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right so here what exactly we do
is we make use of a keyword continue to
skip a particular loop cycle
say in this case we have a for loop
which displays the values
of i ranging from 1 to 10.
however we want to skip the cycle when
it reaches the value three
so what we do is we make use of the
keyword continue here
so basically it displays one and two and
skips the third cycle
and then directly displays four all
right so
let me show you in our vs code editor
here let me just remove this
and save
if x equals
five
i'm going to continue all right
after which
i'm going to say dot log
of x so let me
save this and then execute it
so here let me refresh the page
and there we go as you can see it
displays one two
three and four and the fifth cycle
is kept all right and the rest of the
digits
are displayed so that is how you can
skip a loop
i highly suggest you also practice all
of this
and then play around with loops to get a
better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about javascript
objects so without further ado let's
begin and look at what's in store for us
first we'll start by understanding what
a javascript object is
then we learn how to create a javascript
object
and also get to know about the
properties of these objects
after that we'll get familiar with using
javascript methods
lastly we'll understand what javascript
accessors
are
so what is a javascript object
javascript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
java is an object
a javascript object is like a real-world
entity
having state and behavior for example a
car
now we can take a car as an object it
will have its state like color and model
it will also have behaviors like
accelerate and break
javascript is template based and we can
create objects
without having the need to create a
class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints
but javascript doesn't require any class
to be defined for objects
moving on to the next concept to create
a javascript object
now basically there are three different
ways of creating a javascript object
all right so we look at them one by one
the first one
is to use a literal to create and define
a javascript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then i suggest you go
through the previous video that is
javascript
arrays to get you started with it
so here i've created a folder called
demo objects and now i'm going to create
a file
called create underscore
objects dot html
all right so we'll begin by writing the
initial code
that is the head and the body so i say
html
but in this i create the head tag
[Music]
and then i create a title tag
and let's say javascript
objects
then after the head tag i'm going to
create a body tag
and let's create a heading and say
creating javascript
objects okay
and now we create an id
all of this is explained in the previous
video i really suggest you go through
the video before
hand so that you get a clear picture
and then i say id equals
say demo and then i'm gonna close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an
object is by using object literals right
so what we can do is say script
within which i declare a variable
say where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties
now this is basically like a dictionary
it has
a property a key and then a value
okay so i say name property
and let's say chris
and then another property say age and
say 21
and another property say studies
and say maybe computer science
okay so this is the syntax used to
create an object using an object
literally
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this
right now we want to display the message
saying chris
of age 21 studies computer science
so what we can do is say document dot
get element by id
and the id that we're going to pass is
demo
and we say in html
equals
student dot name which is chris
after which we display the message
of the age
and then the age that is student dot age
studies
student dot
studies
okay let's save this and when we
execute the file it says chris of the
age 21 studies computer science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a javascript object
it is to use the new keyword now this is
the most traditional way of creating an
object
right so let's go back to our vs code
let's create another script
within which we say
where student equals new
object i'm sure everybody has learned
the same way
the same syntax so this is one of the
ways after which we can say student
top name equals chris
again student dot age
equals 21
[Music]
and then student dot
studies equals
computer science
[Music]
all right now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
[Music]
all right so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
chris of the age 21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create
an object all right so then moving on to
the third method
it is to use an object constructor to
create and define
a javascript object so let's go back to
our code editor
and here
we define a function so we say function
say start with three parameters
that is name age
and say studies
okay and now within the function
we use the keyword this so we say this
dot name equals name
all right we say this dot age
equals h we say this top
studies equals
studies now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function
so we say where student
equals stud and within braces we say
chris comma 21
comma computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this we're going to copy the same
print message here
[Music]
all right so let's save this and execute
our file
so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message chris of the age 21
studies computer science so this was the
third method that can be used to create
objects moving on to the next topic
object properties now a javascript
object is basically a collection of
unordered properties right values
associated with the javascript object
are called its properties and properties
can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties
so now let's have a look at the demo to
help you understand this better
so let me go back to my vs code
so this is where we left off and this is
how we
created objects right so now let me
create another file
and let me call it objects underscore
properties
dot html and now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to copy the first piece of
code here
all right let me just copy this into my
new file and here as you can see
student is the object that we've created
and name agent studies are the three
properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do
is here we can just say student
dot h equals
let me change it to 24 all right
and let me save this and when we execute
the file
that was object underscore properties
you can see chris of age 24. so 21
is updated to 24. so this is one of the
ways you can do it
or there's another method you can just
assign
the property to a variable and then
display the variable instead
so what we can do is we can just assign
student.h
to a property say x and here instead
of displaying student.age we can just
say
x all right so let's save this
and when we run it it says 21 because we
haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 remains the same
so another method we can use
is we can just say x equals
h so we're directly assigning the
property to the variable
and here when i'm displaying it
i say student of x
all right so let me save this
and when you look at the web page it
still displays the same thing
these are different ways of accessing
the properties you can update them
delete them
unless they're read only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods
now basically a javascript method is an
action that can be performed on the
objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to rbs code and here
i've created another
html file called objects underscore
methods
all right so let's let me just copy the
initial
code paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
and html all right now here i declare
another tag that is the button tag
so we're going to be making this a
button here so i say
button id equals
click me so that is the action that i'm
going to be performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
okay all right
so we're going to see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so i say script
within which i create
[Music]
the user object
[Music]
so we created using a object little here
and i declare the property name as
this again and age
say 24 okay
so let's close this all right
so the next thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to create a new function
that we will use as an object method
all right so i say function and let's
give the name
say hi okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message so we're
going to say
alert and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
so now once the declaration is done
what we're going to do is we're going to
use
create another property basically say
user dot
let's say message
and assign say hi to it
so basically what we're doing is we're
adding the previously created method
to a new property that is user dot
message
the message property all right
so now i say
document dot get element by id
and say demo
[Music]
and the message that i want is just hi
plus the username all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say let's just
copy this
[Music]
and here instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the id
click me as per this
and the event is going to be on click
event
so here i say on click
after which i'm going to simply pass
user dot message
let me just delete this
all right so here i noticed that i've
given an
equal to sign i'm sorry it's a colon
all right so let's save the file
and let's go ahead and execute it
all right so here you can see hi chris
being displayed
and once we click on the button you can
see
an alert which says hello all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is java object accessors
now getters and setters allow defining
an object
accessor all right to get the value of a
property
in a javascript object we use a getter
and to set the value of a property of a
javascript object
we use a setup so let's go back to our
demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object accessors
and now again let me just copy the first
initial part
all right so now let's go ahead and
create
a new object so let me say script
within which i say where and let's call
it
car all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and the model is say bmw
320d and
another property say color and let's say
it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
and let's say it's diesel
[Music]
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so i say get
and say fuel
within which i return
this dot fuel type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it document dot
get element by id
demo dot inner html
equals we say car
dot fuel all right
so now let's save it and execute our
file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand setter let's
go ahead
and create another
object all right say
where car again
now let's say the model is
audi a4
color would be bright red
[Music]
and fuel type let's keep it blank
all right now to set the value we use
the set keyword
we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel within which
we say this dot fuel type
equals fuel right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot fuel
equals petrol
all right now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here
we say fuel type so let's save this
and let's go ahead and execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol so
what it does is basically it assigns the
value petrol
to the property fuel type and then we
display the same on our web page
so this is how you make use of getters
and setters
we're going to be learning all about
javascript this keyword
so without further delay let's jump
right in
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times
so in javascript this keyword basically
refers to an
object which is executing the current
piece of code
well in simple terms this keyword
basically just references the object
that is executing the current function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function
then this keyword references the global
object
all right i'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an
object then this keyword references the
object itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify
all your doubts let's look at a simple
demo
so here in vs code i've created a file
called this.html
all right you can give it a name of your
choice now here
let me first define a variable
and let's call the variable say
value and let's set it to say 50
all right now let's go ahead and create
a simple function
so let me say function
[Music]
my function all right
and within this let me define the value
for value let me set the value for
the variable value as hundred
okay
and now let me just alert it all right
so let me say
alert
value okay
plus value and then let me have another
alert message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say
this value
and instead of just saying value i say
this
dot value all right
now after this let's go ahead and call
the function
my function so let me just
save this and execute it
so here it says value equals hundred
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50.
so now here you can come back to the
code and see
now when i just say value it takes the
value 100
all right which is taken locally but
when i say this dot value since it is a
normal function
it's references to the global variable
which is here
this value i hope this makes sense to
you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of this keyword
within an object method so let me create
an object here
but before that let me just comment this
out
let's say script and now let's create
an object so
let's say const
and then i give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name and
let's call it john
and then i create a method called info
okay and within this i display a console
message
that says hi my name is
and now i make use of this keyword i say
this
dot name all right
and now let me just go ahead and call
this method
so i say random dot
info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
john
so if you clearly observe here when we
say this dot name
since it is being used within a method
that is defined inside an object
it references to this property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was
mentioned outside so i hope this helped
you understand the difference between
the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just
change the value of name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an
array so let me just call the property
video
within which i have an add a let's say
javascript
another value say
this and then let's say
keyword and in my info method i'm going
to just display these video tags
so let me just save
this okay let me just delete this first
and let's see this dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each intern takes a callback
function
and then i say
i'm going to call it a tag
the parameter that's being passed within
which i just console
log it and say
tag all right so let me save it
and then execute this
now here you can see that the values in
the video property
are displayed that is javascript this
and keyword
now let's suppose that you want to
display the name along with
every string here right so
naturally you would go ahead and just
say
this dot name right it makes perfect
sense
so let me just save and execute this
now if you see just the values of the
property video are displayed
here now the main reason for this is
if you closely observe that this
function here is mentioned
within the callback function right so
when it is referencing it is referencing
to the global
object which is unclear which is
undefined in this case
so to overcome this what we can do is
that
the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object
so here we just pass this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object that is
random so let me save this and then
execute it
and there you go you can see that
tutorial that is the name
has been displayed
all right i hope you understood the
concept of this keyword
it could be a little tricky but as you
work on it you'll get the hang of it
we're going to learn all about
javascript functions
in our previous videos we've covered
topics like javascript arrays and loops
if you're new to this topic i suggest
you go through these topics before
all right so before jumping in let's go
ahead and look at what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
javascript functions are
then we'll look at javascript function
expressions
then the function constructor
self-invoking functions
functions as values functions as objects
arrow functions generator function and
the predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to our first topic what are
javascript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code
which can be called from anywhere in
your program right
when you have a piece of code that you
want to execute repeatedly in your
entire program
it makes more sense to define it once
and call it over and over
right it makes the code more efficient
and readable
this also helps programmers write
modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function
keyword followed by which you mentioned
the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice
next you mention the parameter list and
within curly braces
you can define the function now the
function body is basically the code that
is executed every time the function is
called
so let's go to our vs code editor and
here i created a folder called demo
functions
within which i've created an html file
called functions.html
all right and now i've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which i use the keyword that is
function keyword
and now i give the name for my function
i say my
underscore function and the function
takes
a parameter say value now this function
basically returns
the square of the digit all right so
within which
i say
element by document.getelementbyid
the id is demo
and now it just displays value into
value
all right so the function basically
displays the square of the number
now outside the function let me call the
function
does my function
let me pass the value 5.
all right now let's save this and
execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25.
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept function
expression
now what we learnt previously was
function declaration
but a function can also be defined as an
expression
now this is what the syntax looks like
now here the function is created
and assigned to the variable explicitly
like any other value the meaning remains
the same
that is you create the function and
store the value that it returns
into a variable and in our case it's x
right so let's go to our vs code and let
me help you
understand this better so now
i create another function
and here i say let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
i
just mentioned function and within
curly braces i display an alert message
and i display a message saying hello
all right now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
output code and replace it here
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value x
right now since it consists of a
function you will have to type
the curly braces now this is crucial for
its execution
all right so let me save this and then
execute
let me execute this and here you go
it says the site says hello so we've
successfully executed
the piece of code we can also assign
this variable x to another variable
and then call that variable instead
right we can say let
y equals x and instead of calling x here
we can simply call y let me save it
and then let me refresh the page and
there we go it still displays a message
hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
constructor
now javascript functions are defined
using the keyword function right
now functions can also be defined using
a javascript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function
called my function and we've used the
keyword new
after which we've used the constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that
the return value next you can call the
function
here right so let me just go back to my
vs code
and now let me just make changes to the
same piece of code here
i create a function say my underscore
function
okay all right let me just change the
name
to my function all right and then
here i use the keyword new
and the function constructor that is
function
[Music]
within which i'm passing all the
parameters
so i have a b
and i'm going to return the sum of the
digits
all right and now while calling the
function
let me just store the value in a
variable say x
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters 2 and 3
all right and now let me
display it so i'm just going to copy
this
and i want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say the sum
is x all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function constructor
next up we learn about self-invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called
now previously when we learnt about
function expressions
we saw that parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression
so here is a syntax for you so what
we've done is we've made sure we've
enclosed the entire function within
parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
and here let me create the function
within the parentheses
and say function it's not taking any
parameters
instead it is going to alert a message
so let me say
hello welcome all right
after which we're going to call the
function so again we have to mention the
parentheses
let's save this and execute
so when we refresh the page it says
hello
welcome so we never call the function
rather it got invoked by itself so these
are self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as values
now in javascript a function is
basically a value
so we can deal with it as a value now
here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function expressions
well no in this case what we do is we
first define the function
and then we assign it to a particular
variable but in the case of expressions
the function definition was defined
during the initialization of the
variable
right and also we had to specify the
parenthesis
in order to call the function so to help
you understand this better let me go
back to our vs code
and here let me just erase this
and let's define a function that returns
the product of two digits so let me just
call it
product which takes two parameters
let me say a and b within which we
return the value
a into b all right
now after this let's create another
variable
say y
equals function oh i'm sorry the name of
the function is product
so product of 2 and 5
all right so this basically returns us
10 right so let me just copy this to
display this on our web page
and here i change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y so let's
save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go
you can see the message the product is
10. now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this
now say i want to multiply the value
with 5 again right so basically this
returns 10 and that value is multiplied
by 5.
so let me save this and
refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50. so this
is how you can make use of functions as
values
moving on to the next topic functions as
objects now javascript functions are a
special type of objects
called function objects now a function
includes a string
which holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function
the code is literally just a string
although not recommended you can also
create
a function with the help of the function
constructor
i will show that you a little later on
but for now
let's look at the syntax now here we
have
a variable called body which basically
consists of the function body
it's enclosed in double quotes and
that's a mistake please ignore it
all right so next we have variable
function name
here we create a function using the
keyword new and then we pass a parameter
list
and the body basically tells us what the
function returns
all right next we have an alert message
to call the function so
let me just show how this is executed
back in our vs code let me create
another function
and let's say the function returns the
area of a circle
right so let me just create a body
variable
which returns so the area of a circle is
pi
r square so we make use of math
dot i into
radius into radius
right so it's basically pi r square
after which let's see
where circle and here let's create a
function using the new keyword
function and then here we pass
the value that is the radius and then
the body right so basically
this is the definition of our function
so let's use alert to display the area
so we say alert of circle
of five all right
let me save this and execute it
so when you refresh the page it displays
the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of arrow functions
all right now arrow function expressions
are ill-suited as methods and they
cannot be used as constructors
now also while using arrow functions
using const is a safer option
because a function expression is always
a constant value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword
within the curly braces if the function
is a single statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign followed by the
argument list
and later you make use of this arrow
icon and define the expression
so this is basically nothing but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for ourselves
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const my function
equals now say we want to display the
product of three digits
so let me just pass a b c of my
parameters
and we make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which i say return a
into b into c all right
now let me just assign this to a
variable here let me say
product because we've used x here
and then let me call my function that is
my func
and pass the value 2 3 and say 4.
all right so let's display the product
so let me just copy this
code and here let me say the product
of the three digits
is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle
all right and then we say okay and there
we go
it displays the message the product of
the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay let me save it and then execute it
again
it just displace this all right so this
is how we can make use of arrow
functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value
right or a single value or sometimes
even nothing
but a generator function can return
multiple values
and the speciality is that it can do it
so on demand
all right now to create a generator
function we make use of an asterisk
so an asterisk indicates that the
function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we've
created a function called generator
sequence
so here you can see we have the asterisk
after the keyword function
followed by the name of the function
right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method
when this method is called it basically
runs the execution
until the nearest yield value all right
or the nearest eel statement
then the function execution pauses and
the yielded value
is returned to the outer code
all right so the result of the next
method
is always an object with two properties
it has a value property which is
basically the yielded value
and then it has a done property which
displays true
if the function code is finished or
false if it's otherwise
so let me show it execution for a
clearer understanding
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let's create the generator
function
let's say function asterisk
generate function
all right now within which
i make use of the keyword yield
and i say yield 1 first
followed by yield 2
and finally i make use of return which
indicates the termination so i say
return
3 all right
now let me make use of a variable
say generator
[Music]
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
func and now i create another variable
say 1 which will basically
return the value when i call the next
function so here i say generator
dot next
okay so whatever generator dot next
returns it's stored in one
so to display the message i say alert
and now i'm going to make use of a
method called json.stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a javascript object
or a value to a json string all right so
within which
i'm going to say 1
that is this all right so now let me
save this
and execute it let me
refresh the page and there you go here
it returns two properties that is value
and done
it says value is one and done is false
right it is false because we haven't
reached the return statement yet
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
see there let's see this and here let me
say 2
and this is 3
let me copy this
okay here i say 2
and then i say 3. all right so let me
save this and then execute it
so when i refresh the page it says one
and false
which again it says to and false
[Music]
and finally when it displays three it
returns true for the done
property that means we've reached the
end of the function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now javascript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them
we have eval parse end pass float escape
and unescape now let's go through one by
one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value
all right so to help you understand this
better let me go back to our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it
predefined
functions.html all right
and i've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval
the syntax is eval within which
i say expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression
and if the result is not a string the
result is just returned
and if the result is a string it is
taken to be a javascript program
and evaluated so let me show you how
it's done
so first let's create three variables
all right let's call them x
and initialize it to five
then y with six
and then let z be seven
all right now let's just displace
the result on the console so say
console.log
eval
of let me say x plus y
all right after which i again say
console.log
of eval of z
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated
and here since it's not a string it just
returns the value z
and here since it is not a string it
just returns the value of z
so let me save this and then execute it
all right so let me just check
our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values
that is x and y and returned 11
while z is returned as it is all right
this is what
eval does next up is parseint
now as the name suggests it parses a
string argument
and returns an integer of the specified
radix or
base and the syntax basically includes
the
keyword parse and the string within
parenthesis
parse float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
point number
again the syntax has the keyword parse
float along with the string within
parenthesis
next up is escape now this returns a
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape returns
the ascii string for the specified value
we're going to learn all about
javascript form validation
so what exactly is form validation
now i'm sure you must have filled
several online forms
right a simple example would be a new
registration for a website
now every time you miss out on giving a
particular detail
or end up giving faulty information the
website
alerts you so this process of ensuring
that the information
provided is legit is called form
validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however javascript facilitates
form validation on the client computer
before sending it over to the server
now there are two functions performed
one is the basic validation
which ensures that all the mandatory
fields are filled
now this is implemented with the help of
a simple loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better
let's look at a simple demo
all right so back in my visual studio
code i've created a file called
forms alright it's an html file and i've
typed down the initial
code now the simple use case that i'm
going to show
will include the validation of the email
and the password fields in a form
all right so for that let's go ahead and
first create a simple form
so here html allows the form tag
so i'll say form within which i'm going
to provide
our fields so i say input
and then the name i'm going to be
providing is email
[Music]
all right and then i'll provide a
placeholder and call it
email
and then the type of the input is going
to be text
all right and then let me just give a
free tag here
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here we go i say
password here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
[Music]
and then i'm going to keep the type as
text
and finally i'm going to have a button a
submit button right
so let me say button
type is basically submit all right
and let me just play submit on my button
all right
okay so with the help of this we've
created a simple
form so let me show you how this looks
so here we go we have successfully
created an email field
a password field and a submit button and
every time i click on the submit button
you can see that my page is getting
refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email id and password
we want to display a message all right
so for that i've created another file
called message.html and this is the
simple file where i'm displaying the
message hello there welcome
all right so this is a simple message
that i want to display
so for that i have to add it in my form
tag
now once the form gets submitted an
action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file
right so let me just say action
[Music]
equals message.html
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
my form all right
so let me just save this
all right so moving on we have to now
validate the information
that is provided for that i'm going to
create a function here
so let me call the function
validate all right
so here i'm going to check for my fields
right
now if the email field is empty
then i'm going to alert the user saying
please enter the email
and if the password field is empty i'm
going to again alert the user to provide
the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic
so let me say if
document dot
my form
[Music]
dot email
[Music]
dot value is null
so i'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field
in my form is null all right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
alert
please provide
your email id
okay and then i'm going to say
document.myform.email.focus
now what exactly focus does is that it
makes sure that the cursor remains
at the email field that is it is focused
at the same field
all right so let me just copy the same
thing
for my password field so let me say
else if
let me just copy this
instead of email i say password
within which i'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
i'll say please provide
your password all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field
so let me just say finally else
do nothing all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click
on the submit button the form gets
submitted
correct now we can control when the form
is getting submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function
is executed so for that we can use
another property here
called on submit and here
i'm going to call my function that is
validate so let me say validate
here all right so let me save this
and let's check the output
so here as you can see let me just try
submitting it without providing the
email field
all right so here we go it alerts us all
right and once i click on
ok it still displays the message hello
there welcome
now that is not what we want right so
once the email field is
empty it should remain in the same page
and the form shouldn't get submitted but
here in our case it is getting submitted
so for that we're going to have to make
use of return values
so what happens is if my email field is
empty then i'm going to return
a false so here i say return
false
and here as well
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are
filled i'm going to return true
all right and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate
right so
here we go let me save this
and now let's check the output so here
let's first submit the form without
providing any information
all right so it says please provide your
email id when i click on ok observe that
the cursor remains at the email field
so here let me just give some random
value and then let's try submitting it
again without providing the password
and then it says please provide your
password all right
okay now if you observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field
so let me just check my code once
here we go i haven't mentioned password
here
so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit and then i get a message
saying please provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right
so let me just give random information
there
and then i say submit and here we go
the message hello there welcome is
displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so i really suggest you pause the video
here and then
go through the code once we're going to
learn all about javascript regular
expressions
so now without further delay let's begin
so what exactly are regular expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits
or the letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches
for a particular pattern now the user
can basically define
what has to be searched in a text all
right
and these expressions could be alphabet
or digits as i explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular expressions
is for text search and text replacement
operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked
and you have a flag associated with it
so further on in the video i'll explain
to you what flags and patterns
are but before that let me give you a
small example
of what a regular expression is
so i have made use of this website
called regexar.com
i'll link it down in the description box
below so this is the website
now here let me just show you a simple
regular expression
now say we have a text that says apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter
a so what i do here now this is going to
be my expression
so i first provide a pattern right so i
just say capital a
so when i say capital a you can see that
the letter a
has been matched in my text all right
so it's as simple as that now one thing
to remember
is that here it is case sensitive all
right so if i
say a regular small a it does not get
matched
all right so if i want to match ap i can
just say ap
and it gets highlighted here all right
so this is a simple regular expression
that matches with the text
so moving on let's see what exactly
these flags patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern
and then a flag right so these flags
basically specify
to alter the behavior of a regular
expression now these flags are generally
appended after the red x literal
and can be specified as a second
argument in your expression
right so let's see the different flags
that are supported by javascript
now you have these five flags here you
have g
which is the global flag now this finds
all matches instead of stopping after
the first
all right then you have i which is
ignore case which makes the entire
expression case insensitive and then you
have m
which is multi-line so the carrot and
the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively
then you have unicode and if this flag
is not supported
you must match specific unicode
characters and then finally you have y
which finds all the consecutive or
adjacent matches
so moving on we have patterns
now these patterns are basically
brackets and are used to find the range
of characters
now again we have these patterns you
have a to z
which finds all the characters from a to
z in lower cases only
then we have 0 to 9 which finds all the
digits between 0 to 9
and finally we have the letters of the
alphabet and the digits separated by a
pipe
all right so this basically finds any
character be it an alphabet
or a digit i hope this was clear to you
so moving on we have quantifiers now
these quantifiers define the number of
occurrences of a particular string
now consider l to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisk and we have the
question mark
so plus indicates one or more occurrence
of the character
n all right and the asterisk indicates
zero or more occurrences of the
character n while a question mark
indicates
zero or one occurrence of the character
n so now that you know flags
patterns and quantifiers let me help you
understand them better with the help of
a demo alright so here i have a simple
text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
javascript
this video teaches regular expressions
now here
when i search for a particular word see
let me search for the word
this okay so i say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted
right however it does not that is
because as mentioned earlier
it is extremely case sensitive right so
what we can do is here we have flags
so here i say case insensitive so once i
click on that
both these words get highlighted
all right so this is how you make use of
the i flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns
now as mentioned you can have a range of
characters now just in case here
say i just make it case sensitive again
and here i would like to select all the
letters of the alphabet
from a to z all right
so when i do that you can observe all
the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the upper
case
correct because that is not mentioned
here so here when i make it
insensitive you can see all of them get
highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers let me use
a separate
text all right let's have a couple of
a's
and a few b's now here
when i say a you can see all
the characters a are being highlighted
right which is correct
but when i use the asterisks symbol here
what happens is you can observe all the
four a's are considered to be a single
unit
what asterisk does is that you can see
here it says match is zero or more
of the preceding token now the preceding
token is a
and matches 0 or more occurrences of the
character a
now same if i say b next to it you can
see
all the characters b are matched right
however you can check the characters a
in this particular text are not
highlighted
i'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that i'm looking for
is any occurrences of a followed by
the character b in this text here there
are no characters a
and b together correct so here you can
see that
a is not highlighted but once i give an
asterisk again
what happens is that the character a
gets highlighted
what happens is that b can have zero or
more occurrences
so here there is a zero occurrence of b
so a gets highlighted
so this is how the asterisk quantifier
works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions
are the special characters so here we're
gonna indicate the special characters
with the backslash
so we have backslash w for example
now what w does is that it matches any
word character
right so all the characters here get
matched
now it also has the counter character
which is the capital w
all right so what this does is that it
does not match
any word so it matches everything that
is not a word
including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character
s here all right and when you have the
uppercase
s it matches any character that is not a
white space
now let's say you want to match a digit
you can just have backslash d so let me
just type in a few digits
and here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get
matched right now let's say i want to
match just
three digits so i can make use of curly
braces
and within which i can mention three now
here you can see that it matches
three of the preceding token correct so
the preceding token is basically a digit
so it groups them in threes so let me
just
add two other digits and there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here
let me say w
so when i say three all the characters
are grouped in threes all right now
let's say i want to group the words
that are three or four in number so here
i can just say
comma four all right now it gets
matched all right so now it gets grouped
in force so this is a simple example to
show you how
special characters work in a regular
expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular expressions
to search for phone numbers now here
in my phone number i'm going to have
an area code so let's say 0 8
0 followed by a new digit number all
right
so let me give a random number
all right so it's eight digits so some
people write
a phone number like this while others
could write it something like this
you could have a hyphen in between and
then
an eight digit number all right now how
are you going to look for this
text so what we're going to do is we're
going to make use
of the special character that is for a
digit
we'll make use of hyphen d and first
we're going to look
for the area code that is a three digit
number right
so let me just say three here
and next we are going to have an
optional hyphen so for that
now since we learnt a pattern can be
enclosed within square brackets
so let me just say hyphen here
and let me say a question mark now a
question mark indicates
zero or one occurrence of the preceding
character
right so we're gonna have a hyphen for a
question mark and then finally we're
going to have
a digit again and here
the number of digits is 8. so let me
just specify that
all right so when this happens you can
see both my numbers are getting
highlighted
although the text remains the same it
could be specified with different
formats
right so just like this you can create
expressions that match various formats
so this was just a simple video to
acquaint you with regular expressions
we're going to be learning all about
javascript email validation
let's begin
so first of all validation is an
essential part when you're communicating
with the user
almost all the websites and applications
that you use
have forms that you need to fill in and
every time you fill a form
that information you provide needs to be
validated
so this is an essential and a crucial
part now when you're providing more
critical information like user
credentials say your
id your password your date of birth all
of that needs to be validated
so javascript enables this with the help
of a feature called email validation
now email validation first of all
ensures user authenticity
it also facilitates email validation on
the client side
so that all the processing that takes
place on the server side is faster
and lastly with javascript one can
validate a name
password email date etc now i'm sure
everybody has used email ids
right so here's a dummy email id for you
one thing that you must have noticed
is that all ids come with an ad symbol
now the first part before the act
character is the personal data
now here it could include your name you
can provide digits etc
so the length of this personal
information can be up to 64 degrees
and following the at character you have
the domain name
the domain name can be up to 253
characters
talking about the personal data now this
data can include
any sort of information you can provide
your name your birth date etc
so basically it can consist of all
uppercase and lowercase letters of the
alphabet
it can have digits from 0 to 9
it can include all special characters
and lastly it could include the period
character
one thing to remember is that the period
character cannot occur twice
and is not supposed to be either the
first or the last character
all right so this was just a brief
introduction to email validation
now to give you a better understanding
let's go ahead and look at a simple demo
so back in our visual studio code i've
created a folder called
javascript demo and i've also created a
file called email validation
i've also typed in the initial code also
if you haven't watched our videos on
javascript regular expressions
and javascript form validation then i
highly recommend you go through them
email validation is basically just a
combination of the two
so i suggest you first head back and
watch those videos and come back here
all right so the first thing that we
need to do is create a form that
includes the email field
right so for that let's go ahead and
create our form
here i'd say
form
within which i give input
let the id be text
and i'll give the placeholder property
and
let it be email
and the type
text all right
and then i will
break the line and finally i have a
button
that's basically the submit button right
so let me just say button
type say button
and then the message displayed is submit
all right so now when you're validating
a form
you will have to provide certain cases
that is the if
else conditions to validate it correct
now first i'm going to create a function
wherein i'm going to pass the
information typed in by the user as an
argument
and this function consists of a regular
expression against which
the id provided by the user is checked
and if the pattern matches it
then the id is valid and if it does not
then you'll have to alert the user
so now let's create our function
let's say script
and now let me create a function
called validate
all right
and now i'm going to create a variable
called mail
and i'm going to get the information
provided
by using this id from the input
now i'm going to get the text using this
id correct
so let me just say document dot get
within which the name of the id is text
let me say text top value all right
so the next thing is to create a regular
expression
now consider two different ids here now
the domain of the first id
ends with dot com while the next one is
ending with
dot co dot n so when we're defining the
regular expression
we'll consider all possible scenarios so
now
let's head back to our vs code and here
let me just say
variable regex
beginning with a forward slash and then
you have a carrot now the carrot symbol
indicates the beginning of the regular
expression
now since we can have the lower cases
uppercases and all the digits
let's go ahead and mention them so here
let me say a to z all lower cases
then we have upper case and we have
all digits 0 to 9. followed by which
you can also include a period and an
underscore so when you're including a
period symbol
you will have to use the escape
character that is backslash
and then you mention the period now
one thing to remember is that a period
symbol
in regular expression means that it can
include
any of the characters but here since
we're using the literal character that
is the period
we have to include backslash after that
we can have
an underscore as well all right
followed by which we have a quantifier
that is
plus now plus here indicates one or more
occurrences
of all these characters so here we
include
plus after which we have a literal that
is
the act symbol followed by which we have
the domain name
so again the domain name can include all
the letters of the alphabet and the
digits
so for that let me say
a to z a to z and 0 to 9.
again to remember we have to include the
plus symbol
indicating that it let me just get rid
of this
so we include the plus symbol to
indicate one or more occurrences of
of these characters again followed by
which we have
a period symbol so for that
let's just go and type in period now you
must be wondering why i didn't use the
backslash
now a backslash or an escape sequence
here can only be used
within the squared braces outside of it
it is considered as a literal
so here i just mentioned the period
again i highly recommend you go through
the javascript regular expressions video
to clarify all your doubts so moving on
after this i have to mention the
extension that is
dot com or dot co dot in now generally
these extensions
are in lower cases so
for that let's just
go ahead and mention a to z
again followed by a plus that is a
quantifier
with an optional dot again
followed by the letters a to z
again these can again i mentioned plus
followed by which i'm going to add the
question mark
now the question mark indicates zero or
one occurrence of the preceding
expression
so in this case this
extension that is dot in is
optional now the question mark here
indicates either a zero occurrence or
one occurrence
all right so uh to end the expression
you have
the dollar symbol and then the front
slash
oh i might have missed something
okay yeah i haven't closed this so let
me just add
the parentheses all right so this is
your regular expression
against which we're going to be checking
the email id right
so now we're going to use the simple if
else logic
so for that let's say if
reg x dot text
dot mail mail is basically what has been
passed by the user all right
now if this is true
that is if the mail when checked against
the regular expression comes in to be
true
then i'm going to alert the user saying
you have
provided
a valid email id and i'm going to return
true
else if the expression does not match
then i'm going to alert the user with a
message
saying sorry
incorrect email id
and i'm going to return a false
so now you must be wondering where is
the return value going
so for that i have to add the on click
event on my button
so here let me say on click
it's going to call the validate function
all right so there we go let me save
this
and execute it in my browser when i type
in
xyz gmail.com and when i click on submit
it alerts me saying you have provided a
valid email id
so to check the other condition as well
let's type in dot co dot
in and submit and again it says that
we've provided a valid email id
now uh let's just add a period and an
underscore as well
so if i say x y z
dot a underscore
bc at gmail dot co dot n and when i
submit it
it again says it's a valid email id
for a false case let's go ahead and
remove
the add symbol and submit it it says
sorry incorrect email id
or you can also go ahead and remove the
period here
and submit it it still says that the id
is valid
now here what happens is that gmail co
is taken as one domain name with an
extension dot
in so here this is valid so this was a
simple video to explain email validation
i encourage you to play around with
regular expressions
and also consider all possible scenarios
while you're
validating your id in a previous few
topics we learned about
areas functions and loops however this
time we're going to take a step forward
and then learn about promises
now you must be wondering why javascript
promises even came into picture and what
exactly these promises are
so don't worry i've got your back in
today's video we're going to learn about
promises
why they were introduced and also i'll
explain their functionality
so let's go ahead
first up why javascript promises
now javascript is predominantly single
threaded
meaning all processes contain the
execution of instructions in a single
sequence
so basically in simple terms one command
is processed at a time now if a function
relies
on the result of another function it
basically has to wait for the other
function to finish
and return and until then the current
function
remains idle now this can be extremely
frustrating
because it's time consuming and very
restrictive i mean you're not using the
system to its full capability
so to overcome these drawbacks
asynchronous concepts or asynchronous
programming came into picture
so in this case the main thread
continues its execution
while javascript allows long network
requests
and other tasks to happen simultaneously
now with the help of features like
callbacks promises and async await
asynchronous programming can be easily
achieved
i hope now you understood why promises
or asynchronous programming came into
picture
moving on what are javascript promises
now in the case of synchronous actions
you could instead of arranging for a
function to be called
at some point in the future return an
object that represents this future event
this is what the standard class promises
for now the promise is basically an
asynchronous action that may complete at
some point in the future
and when it's completed it produces a
value
now it is able to notify when its value
is available
the easiest way to create a promise is
by calling the promise.resolve method
now this function ensures that the value
you give it is wrapped within a promise
now a promise basically has three states
first up is the pending state
now this indicates that the underlying
operation has not yet been completed
next up is the fulfill state this
indicates that the promise has been
fulfilled
with a particular value lastly we have
rejected
now this indicates that an error has
occurred during the operation and the
promise is rejected with a particular
reason
moving on a promise is said to be
settled when it is either fulfilled
or rejected because remember promises
are immutable
they cannot change their state so once
they're either fulfilled or rejected
they're said to be separate so when a
promise is fulfilled it has to do a
particular job
so for that we make use of the then
method now the then method basically
runs for a result
and this is used to attach a callback
when the promise has been resolved
all right same with the case of the
scenario when the promise is rejected
it makes use of a catch method which is
used to attach a callback when the
promise has been rejected
don't worry you'll understand the
concepts better when we get to the demo
so moving on let's look at a quick
flowchart to understand promises better
first up you have a new promise now the
promise is in the pending state
now this promise runs for an
asynchronous action now we check if the
action is successful
if it is a yes then we call the then
method
and if it is a no then the catch method
is called
and to end it if it is fulfilled then
the asynchronous action is performed
and if it is not that is if it is
rejected then error handling is
performed
and lastly the values of these methods
is returned to the promise
i hope this was clear so moving ahead
let's look at the general syntax
you can use the let keyword and provide
a name for your variable
and then you create a new promise now
this promise object takes a function
which in turn takes two parameters that
is resolve and reject
so to help you understand all of this
better let's go ahead and look at a
simple demo
so in vs code i've created a folder
called demo promises
within which i've created an html file
named promises
so i have the initial code ready here so
let's begin typing our code
so let's say script
and here as i explained we say let and
let's
give the name car to our variable
say car and we create a new promise
all right so the promise object returns
a function
which takes two parameters called
resolve
and reject all right
so within the function let's define
a simple use case now let's assume that
we're checking the car
for its fuel all right so we'll create
variable
called fuel underscore
full tank now let's set the variable
to say true all right now let's set the
variable to true
now this indicates that the fuel tank is
full
so now if the fuel tank is full
what i can do is i say resolve
all right else i reject it
okay i hope you understood what i'm
doing here i'm just checking for the
fuel tank and if it is
full which is true then it gets resolved
and if it is false then it gets rejected
so if the promise gets resolved the then
method
is called right so let me call it here
i say car dot then
now this runs a result right so it's a
callback function
within which i say dot
right
the fuel tank
is full
happy driving
all right and if it is
rejected i say dot
catch which also returns a function
that says document dot
right let's just display a simple
message saying that the fuel tank is not
empty
all right so let me save this and
execute it
so here it displays the message the fuel
tank is full happy driving
now that happens because we have set the
value to true here
now in case we change it to false
let's see what it displays
all right it displays the message the
fuel tank is not empty
so this was a simple example showing how
a promise works
now let's go ahead and understand nested
promises
so for that let me just comment this out
and now let's create a function that
returns promises
so in our case what we're going to do is
first we'll check for the fuel tank
now in our case we're taking a scenario
where the fuel tank is empty
and the engine of the car is overheating
so as a result
the car is not safe for traveling all
right so let's go ahead and create these
functions
so i'll say let
empty underscore tank
okay which returns a promise
so within which i say return
new promise
and the function takes two parameters
that is resolve and reject
which in which i'm going to display a
message saying
resolve it says
the car doesn't
have enough fuel
all right
now let me just copy the same piece of
code
to check for the engine all right
so let me just change the name of our
variable here
let's call it engine
and here it displays the message
the engine is overheating
all right and lastly
when both of these scenarios hold true
that is the car doesn't have enough fuel
and the engine is overheating
we say that the car is not fit for
travel
let me just call it travel
and here i'll display a message
saying the car is not safe for traveling
[Music]
all right so right now we've created
three functions that returns promises
so first we check for the empty tank
right
so let me just call the function here
empty tank
and we make use of the then method
which is executed when the promise gets
resolved
which takes a callback function
all right so basically when we check for
the empty tank
after this is executed we check for the
engine
right so here we simply call the engine
function
so let me just say return
engine all right now
this is a nested promise in itself so on
top of it
i can run the then method again
so if the tank is empty and if the
engine is overheating
then i'll just check if it is safe for
traveling or not so let me say
function
[Music]
and here let me just return
the method travel
all right now
after this if all of these are executed
then i say function
finally i'll display a message saying
saying done all right
so let's save this file and execute it
so here i go and click on promises
let's go and check our console
and there we go the message done is
displayed
so here since every time the promise is
being resolved
a message is displayed i can basically
catch the message
in a result okay and this result can be
passed to the coming methods so here i
just say result
i see result again
all right
so now we get the message the car
doesn't have enough fuel
so we have to append it with the next
message so let me just say
message here i've used msg
and let's just append it here
[Music]
and the final message gets appended here
good result okay i have to add
message here as well all right so let's
save it and execute the file
all right so here you can see the
message done gets displayed first
and then since we're appending it after
the message done it says the car doesn't
have enough fuel
the engine is overheating the car is not
safe for travelling
so this was how you can make use of
nested promises
we're going to learn javascript
asynchronous concepts
that is async and away firstly
let's understand the basic concepts of
synchronous and asynchronous programming
in case of synchronous programming all
the actions are performed
sequentially so you have the execution
of the function 1
after which you have function 2 and then
you have function 3
and after all of these are executed the
program terminates
now although synchronous programming is
clean and has lesser errors
it has its own drawbacks the entire
system is halted
when a particular process is being
executed now as a result of which it is
time consuming
and the system is not used to its full
capacity
so to overcome that asynchronous
programming was introduced
now in this case let's assume that a
particular function of a process is
being executed
now let's consider that this particular
function is waiting for a resource
let's say a network resource now instead
of waiting for the function to acquire
this resource
the main thread continues its execution
with function 2 and function 3
and when the resource is acquired it
receives a callback
indicating that the function one has to
be called and finally
the entire chain is terminated so this
is how asynchronous programming works
it makes sure that the system does not
halt when a particular process is
waiting for a resource
this makes the entire system very
efficient
now that you know the concepts of
synchronous and asynchronous programming
let's move ahead now async and await are
purely asynchronous programming concepts
i again suggest you check out the video
on promises before watching this
alright so moving on
what are javascript async functions that
is async
and await now async and await are built
on promises the function
is basically accompanied by the keyword
async
indicating that it returns a promise
within this function the await keyword
is applied to the promise that is being
returned
and the await keyword ensures that the
function waits for the promise to
resolve
now on the surface the execution looks
synchronous while it's actually
asynchronous
now at the place of usage of the await
keyword the execution of the function
is practically blocked now async
functions make the code more readable
and are easy to handle when compared to
promises now to give you the general
syntax
you have the async keyword associated
with the function name
within which we have the await keyword
with a particular promise
now to help you understand the entire
concept better let's look at a demo
now i've created a file called async
await in my visual studio code
so what we're going to be doing is that
we're going to have two functions
that help you check for the result now
you pass this code as a parameter to
these functions
which in turn return promises telling if
you have passed
and will also give you the grade that
you scored all right so let's go ahead
and say let let me call
the variable result and let's have a
function
which takes the score as a parameter
all right within which it returns a
promise
so i save return new promise
now as you know a promise basically
has a function which takes two
parameters that is resolve
and reject
now i just display a message saying
calculating
results
all right now if my score
is say above 50 i resolve it
by displaying a message saying
congratulations
[Music]
you have passed
all right and if it is less than 50
i reject it with the message saying you
have faith
all right so this is a very simple
promise that i created
so moving on let's create another
function that returns a promise
so basically this function will tell you
the grade that you've scored
so say let grade equals
function now this takes response as a
parameter
so let me just say response
now again let me just copy this
all right within which i'm going to
console.log
a message saying
calculating your grade
now we're just going to resolve the
promise with the message
your grade is a all right
and then we append the response
now the first promise either results
saying that you've passed or
it rejects saying you failed and in case
it gets resolved
then the next promise is automatically
resolved with the grade a
all right so moving on let's call the
functions
so here let me first call the function
result
so i say result and let me pass the
value 80
since it gets resolved and now i make
use of the dot then method
now here i catch the response
all right and then i just display a
message indicating
results received
okay now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to pass the response
to my next function that is the grade
function so what i say is i say return
grade and the parameter is response
let me just pass that now what exactly
happens is that
the grade function also returns a
promise so on top of that i can use the
dot then method
so i use the then method and let me just
say
final grade
[Music]
now within which i just display the
message
final grade all right
now lastly we make use of the catch
method
in case of errors this catches the
errors
so let me just say error
and then console.log it
all right so this is the code
let me save this and let's execute it to
see its normal
execution so this is without using async
and await
all right so let's go ahead and execute
this
so here let me check the console
and there we go it says calculating
results results received
calculating your grade your grade is a
and congratulations you have passed
so this was basically without using
async innovate
so now let me show you how you can use
async and await and how
easier the code becomes all right so
what we can do is
let me just comment this out
all right now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to call my function
right so i'm just going to make use of
the async keyword while calling it
so i say async
function and let me call the function
calculate results
okay so now inside this method i'm going
to call the functions
result and grade so when i first call
result the value that is returned by
result is going to be stored in the
variable response
so for that let me just say const
response now i make use of the await
keyword here
i say await result
of 20 or in our case let me just say 80
all right so what the away keyword does
is that the function result
ceases to execute until the promise is
resolved
and whatever the promise returns gets
stored in the variable response
all right so now after this let me just
display a message
that says results
received all right now next i'm going to
call the other function that is
great so again i'm going to say constant
and i'm going to have to create
another variable let me call it final
grade
and it's the same procedure i use the
await keyword
and call the function grade
and i pass response as the argument all
right
and after this i'm going to say
console.log
for final grade so it's as simple as
that
so first we call the result function
which returns
a promise which gets stored in the
variable response
all right then we're going to call the
grade function and pass the response as
an
argument and the result of which is
being stored in final grade
all right and lastly we display final
grade so now you must be wondering if
this executes
what about errors what if the value that
i pass
is less than 50 right for that i'm going
to have to catch an error
so what i can do is that i can place
this entire code within the try block
all right so let me just say try
and now what i can do is i can catch
now if there is an error it gets caught
and then
i display it let me say console.log
error all right
and lastly let's call the function
calculate results okay
so let me save this and execute it
so all right here we go it displays the
same messages in the same sequence that
we saw before
so now to give you an example of
rejection so here let me just pass 20.
all right let's save it and there we go
it says calculating results you have
failed
so you can make use of async and await
instead of complicating the entire piece
of code by using promises
so with that we come to the end of this
crash course video
if you found it helpful then make sure
to give it a thumbs up
if you have any queries let us know in
the comment section below
thank you so much for watching and stay
tuned for more from simply learn